[Music]
after ji
hoon made a step forward and upgraded
devin's apartment
his slow reaction to grabbing drusilla
might just send him
10 steps back hey my 90 day fans fam
it's melisia i'm going to update you on
the biggest
must-see moments from the latest episode
of the other way
let's start things off with devin and ji
hoon moving into their new place
now before i show it to you let's just
take a look at the apartment
devin was staying in when she first got
to korea
where where where are we at where's the
house
this is the new house
her mom was pissed and ji hoon's parents
were disappointed in him
for not checking out the place before
devon and the kids got there
all right somehow jihoon has managed
to come back from that and many other
things
and now he's keeping the promise he made
to devin to step up to the plate
and provide for their family isn't this
so much better
oh this is way better look there's a
playground
there's a nail shop there's a hair shop
let's
[Music]
look at this oh this is so much better
while devin's mom is super happy about
her grandkids and her daughter being in
a
much safer environment she does admit
that there is a part of her that just
wanted all of this to go wrong
i'm really conflicted right now
this place is great that means she's
going to want to stay
i'm happy but at the same time i'm
losing
any ground to getting her back to
america where
i'm just being selfish i know i'm being
selfish now
just to be clear this apartment is only
rented for one month
so jihoon still has to find a place for
them to stay
long-term
after everyone got settled the family
headed to the neighborhood park so
driscilla could play
as you could see driscilla was having
the time of her life
and everyone else was enjoying their
time as well
the adults had a heart to heart and
jihoon reassured everyone
that from now on he's not going to rely
on his parents
and he's going to independently
independently
take care of his family good good
so you better start stepping up
i'm stressed out too yeah
i believe my son will do well let's hope
so
all right good everybody hugs it's all
good
you'll you got this you got this oh
ouch sorry bro oh i wish i could tell
you that that sweet moment right there
lasted for a long time but it didn't
it was short-lived take yourself
upstairs
okay let's go dracella all right let's
go see you later come on
no
you're too heavy
hurry
[Music]
up yeah
[Music]
i can't even tell you where dracilla
went i don't know
i don't know why she didn't stop when
her mom told her to stop
all i know is that based off of the
trailer for next week
something terrible happened i don't even
want to look at jihoon again
all i feel is rage
i can't wait to see what happened but in
the meantime
let's go ahead and move into our final
must-see moment
kenneth popped the question to armando
just two weeks before they are set to go
meet armando's parents who
don't necessarily agree with their
sexuality
i'm totally committed to you
for life but there's something i want to
ask you
and i want to ask you
are you serious empty you will
bury me hey
of course yes
oh the look on armando's face had me a
bit nervous at first i didn't know what
we were gonna get
but yay i'm glad he said yes that's why
i'm here
[Music]
i love you
kenneth made this moment really special
he invited his daughters from the u.s to
witness the whole proposal
which really meant a lot to armando i
was super excited
to see my dad propose to armando it was
awesome
very happy did you even suspect anything
nothing
nothing good
his daughters are important to me i'm
still struggling with my family
accepting me
and the fact that his kids like almost
like approve of me
and to see that they're there to support
us and support our love
it does get to my heart oh that's so
sweet
i love them they're awesome well next
week these two discuss
the tough world that's ahead of them
when it comes to armando's family
accepting their relationship now that
we're officially engaged i want to meet
his parents
as fiances they're going to have to
process meeting you first but you will
tell them
that's a lot of pressure to put on
armando i mean
can we take baby steps here kenny baby
steps
alright 90 day fans fam we want to make
sure you stay updated on all the latest
news
from the 90 day universe so make sure
you stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i'll see
you next time